it is about politicians it's not one
particular party I think all the major
political parties uh have been the you
really when it comes to the NHS just
sort of focusing on focusing on on
almost treating it like a religion like
the rest of the country as though you
know it's above criticism and at the end
of the day we must remember it's a it's
a Health Service uh and it's there we
obviously for all of us but what we want
to add to it are the best outcomes and I
think where politicians get stuck really
is that they are very afraid uh to speak
honestly and openly about the challenges
the NHS and how to fix them because
frankly they just don't want to get
their heads shot off they just feel that
they think that's not what the public
want to hear